so over the weekend we continued to
learn more about the truth and the
falsity of what has been circulating
about Robert mullahs report that he sent
to attorney General William Barr last
Sunday and one of the bits of
information we've learned is that the
molar report meaning the summary of the
investigation is more than 300 pages
long more than 350 pages long according
to some and reportedly 400 pages long
according to a document which we will
look at in the next segment this
immediately raises the obvious questions
that I've been bringing up for a week
now the most obvious of which is how
much can we really know about what's in
a 350 or 400 page report on the basis of
a political for page summary the answer
is very very little there's a New York
Times report and there's a political
report which are bringing up more
important questions we still don't know
the answers to one of those questions is
will Congress ever get an unredacted
full version of the report some say yes
some say no we don't really know how
many pages of underlying evidence and
case files are there there's one
guesstimate which says it's several
hundred thousand if not more than a
million pages of underlying evidence and
case files which Muller summarized into
three to four hundred pages which bar
summarized into four pages will or won't
Donald Trump's lawyers get a chance to
redact some version of the report
conflicting evidence about that in
conflicting assertions which we've been
talking about when William Barr said
last week according to Republican
Senator Lindsey Graham that he would be
releasing a version of the report which
version is that what is implicit about
what will be missing from a version or
that version versus the entire thing so
this is merely the beginning of this
fight the Justice Department or Trump's
lawyers again we don't really know the
truth about who gets to do what now
either of them might try to claim
executive privilege to get portions of
the report redacted the House of
Representatives Democrats in the house
that is will almost definitely question
that assertion of privilege and that
will become a legal fight and one of the
primary quests
is if Muller's three to four hundred
page report can't exonerate Donald Trump
from obstruction which was like one of
the few quotes that bar actually
included in his four-page letter how is
it that William what a bar was able to
so quickly say that there's no
obstruction and why is it barely even
mentioned in his four-page letter and of
course we know the answer I told you the
answer last week which is that the bar
report is a political document it's not
a law enforcement document it's not now
bar is even walking back that it's a
full summary and we'll get to that in
the next segment and by the way what
when I say more than three hundred pages
a couple of people including FoxNews
Judge Andrew Napolitano claimed the
report itself is seven hundred pages the
source is unclear but needless to say
we're talking about a three to four
hundred page report here the 9/11
Commission report was more than five
hundred and fifty pages the Clinton
Special Counsel report was four hundred
and forty five pages as an as an
interesting sort of point of contrast
the Watergate report was under one
hundred pages and we know what that led
to meaning even a short report can
contain significant evidence of
criminality bottom line we still don't
know what molars full conclusions were
we don't know what evidence
Robert Muller gathered in those possibly
million-plus pages of evidence and case
files
the one thing and I guess this is a good
thing that Americans seem to be able to
agree on is that they want the full
report we have a Quinnipiac poll from
last week that I told you about eighty
five percent of americans eighty four
maybe want to see the full molar report
that means that it's most Republicans
it's most Democrats it's most
independents all want to see the report
will we ever see what we could call a
full report with only the absolutely
necessary redactions I actually have no
idea at this point in time the initial
deadline for a version to go to Congress
is tomorrow April 2nd I'll follow up
with you tomorrow about it i I couldn't
tell you what it is that we might or
might not see this week today's program
is sponsored in part by expressvpn it
might feel like cybercrime is something
that happens just to other people but
stealing data from one suspect
people on public Wi-Fi is a really
simple way for hackers to make money
when you leave your internet connection
unencrypted you might as well be writing
your passwords and credit card numbers
on a huge billboard for the world to see
and you can protect yourself with
expressvpn which secures and anonymizes
your internet browsing by encrypting
your data hiding your public IP address
expressvpn has easy-to-use apps that run
seamlessly in the background of your
computer phone and tablet turning on
expressvpn protection takes just one
click it costs under seven bucks a month
and expressvpn is the number one rated
VPN service by tech radar and comes with
a 30-day money-back guarantee protect
your online activity today and find out
how you can get three months free at
expressvpn comm slash Pakman that's exp
ress VPN dot-com slash Pakman four three
months free with a one-year package
visit expressvpn dot-com slash Pakman to
learn more